[Music]
[Applause]
I'm here with Jeremy Godfrey the chair
of Burak Jeremy thanks for talking to us
tell us about this panel that you took
part in earlier today so the panel was
about what next for the European
institutions following the European
electronic communications code which
came into force last December and he's
been transposed over the next two years
so what I talked about was first of all
the role of Barrack in implementing that
code so Barracks role is to ensure a
consistent application of telecoms law
across europe and in the code there are
many sets of guidelines that Merrick is
mandated to do to make sure that the
national regulatory agencies the nras
across Europe applied the code in a
consistent manner so I first what I
talked about the work those elements of
the Verret work program and then I also
talked about the what I thought the
agenda might be for the incoming
Commission and incoming Parliament's who
are going to come in you're going to
take up their roles during later later
this year so the I'm quite sure that
digital issues will be a big theme for
the next commission I think it probably
they probably won't want to redo the
communications law again because it
because it will only be coming into full
force after two years and there would
need time to see how that works but I
think there will be a number of issues
related to the data economy
there are issues around new forms of
market power in the data economy for
example the platform's having large
amounts of data which it's difficult for
new entrants innovative new companies to
replicate there are issues around
privacy there are issues of societal
harm like fake news hate speech
disruption of elections and so forth
there are new forms of great new
potential benefits that can be got as
well in terms of things like
epidemiology you met here and medical
research keeping us the traffic moving
in smart cities and then of course that
all the potential applications of
artificial intelligence
they were just scraping the surface on
so I think there will be a huge number
of issues about how best to enable
Europe to take the you the benefits of
the digital economy but also how to
build confidence amongst end-users that
the data economy is is going to work for
them and isn't going to work against
their interests what are the
implications for the fibre community so
I think there's still a big push for
investments in fiber and in very high
capacity networks so there are a number
of regulatory issues around very high
capacity networks which Barrett will be
working on we are doing guidelines to
define what is meant by very high
capacity network so what technologies
that maybe complement fiber can so
qualify as very high capacity networks
what forms of regulatory
lighter forms of regulation might apply
stake to wholesale only networks of
which many members of the
fiber-to-the-home
Council Europe are in that are in that
business so I think from the fiber
community
there's nothing aims at once who give us
lots of inputs I think this morning I
had a meeting with some of the CEOs and
there was very interesting insights
about the problems they see some of the
some different types of competition
problems that they say that that they
think regulators and policy makers might
need to address so I think engagement
continued engagement with barek with
local regulators with the with the
Commission and with policy makers in
Member States going to be very important
you certainly seem to be very busy at
the moment to the benefit of our viewers
tell us what about barek and what it
does so Burak consists of the national
regulatory authorities for electronic
communications from each of the Member
States and then we also have other
people who attend beric meetings from
the ei countries and from accession
states and so forth and the primary role
of Barrack is to help facilitate a
consistent application of
telecommunications law across Europe so
in this year's work program most of what
we're doing is his guidelines for the
codes looking again the direct
guidelines on net neutrality so as I say
making sure that we have a very sensible
level of harmonization so that
pan-european operators investors and so
forth have a degree of predictability
about how individual national regulatory
authorities will apply them as a very
important angle for us but we as well as
as well as focusing on that we also have
a role in contributing to discussions
about forward-looking
issues so we're doing a piece of work on
the dynamics of investments in very high
capacity networks which is right at the
heart of what members of the
fiber-to-the-home Council Europe will
will care about so we want to understand
not what's the role of competition
what's the role of what can be done to
help help demand to develop fast what
should be done about about things like
copper switch off these are all issues
that will be part of that study so it's
a high-level study that looks at how all
those things interact with one another
and will then help us decide where we
need to focus our efforts we're also
looking at 5g so fibre of course will be
a very important component to 5g
networks I mean in a way 5g networks are
basically fiber networks with wireless
on the end of them and looking at again
what are all the issues regulators and
policy makers mean may need to look at
to enable innovation in the 5g ecosystem
enable innovation in IOT so we're
looking at some of those future looking
things and lastly Berek is wants to
wants to further deepen its engagement
with stakeholders so we are looking to
engage with the stakeholders of the
earlier stage in our projects so before
we actually put pen to paper and draft
guidelines
we'd like to kind of gather some input
we want to give ourselves a bit longer
to respond to our consultations and we
want to give them a
a formal opportunity to propose ideas
for our work program so those are the
three things that Barrett will be doing
this year working on the on the court on
the on a consistent application of
telecoms law in Europe contributing
forward-looking debates and engaging
more effectively the stakeholders well
thank you very much for speaking to us
it sounds like you've got a very busy
rest of the year ahead thank you thank
you very much
[Music]
you